an American college student held in
North Korea for 17 months is back home
but he is in a coma a medevac plane
carrying otto warmbier arrived last
night in Cincinnati he had been serving
a 15 year prison term for alleged anti
state acts his parents told The
Associated Press quote we want the world
to know how we and our son have been
brutalized and terrorized by the pariah
regime then Tracy's in Beijing with
details of the 22 year olds early
release Ben good morning good morning so
the State Department says that it was
notified by North Korea last week about
warm beers condition a US delegation
that went to Pyongyang and demanded his
release on humanitarian grounds
apparently warmbier had been in a coma
for more than a year otto warmbier
arrived home in cincinnati on a medevac
flight late last night an ambulance
carrying the 22 year old rushed
immediately from the airport to a nearby
hospital the last time he was seen in
public he was being paraded through the
halls of the North Korean supreme court
in handcuffs his crime ripping down a
propaganda poster in a Pyongyang hotel I
made the worst mistake of my life
the University of Virginia student gave
a tearful and seemingly coerced
confession saying he was manipulated by
the US government I entirely beg you for
your forgiveness his parents told The
Washington Post that North Korea claims
warmbier fell into a coma shortly after
his one-hour trial in March of last year
they say he became ill with botulism and
was given a sleeping pill US
intelligence reports obtained by the New
York Times indicate warmbier had been
repeatedly beaten and there were
concerns he had died Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson credited President Trump
with pushing for warm beers release we
continue our discussions with the North
Korean regime regarding the release of
the three other American citizens that
have been detained why was he in a coma
former UN Ambassador bill Richardson
sent a team to North Korea last year to
try to free warm beer I think Kim
jong-un the leader has some explaining
to do the excuse the North Koreans of
given doesn't wash
now warm beers parents do plan to hold a
news conference tomorrow and may shed
some more light on what exactly happened
to their son meanwhile the condition of
those three other Americans still held
by North Korea is unknown
all right then Tracy in Beijing thank
you